we have the hot guy draft people that
we'd like to look like if we had the
chance I like the fact that normally you
wouldn't bring up this conversation but
if somebody else brought it up then
you'd weigh in on it so all these guys
tweet to him tell him seat me made a
good draft pick their who called in here
bowling three round draft and the hot
guy draft and someone wants to find out
what the results are it's actor friend
of the show Josh Duhamel oh my - a set
Wow hey Josh I was listening when this
whole thing was proposed and I went into
practice with my son I got a call from
Paul and it was just curious how that
all went
what do you how did it go like like
where you went and a four-round around
did anybody take Josh Duhamel and a hot
guide man
you went undrafted what yeah yeah yeah
but you're you're able to sign with
another team okay you you're a free
agent
you're like in the Supplemental Draft at
what Seton okay we found a way to make
Josh an underdog here in this storm yeah
this is gonna be they're gonna make
movies about this someday okay well
we're journalists we got to get the big
stars on this is what TMZ once they want
the honest reaction from me by the way
by the way Fergie's video the new album
Congrats man you told us about it a
while ago she looks great and I was
gonna text you last night and I thought
it might sound weird if I said boy your
wife looks really great but she does in
the video okay good the whole thing soon
I guess I don't know sometimes I quit
asking a while ago she's killing it now
tell her we set a low now I want to ask
you if you had the first pick in the hot
guy draft and you can't take
yourself how would you take if I had
first picking a hot guy giraffe to it I
think I would probably take I have to go
with with Chad Greenway Chad Greenway
Vikings linebacker understand yeah yeah
understandable big burly yeah yeah they
might need you to play quarterback in
Minnesota there John you know we could
have had Derek Carr a lot of teams could
have had Derek Carr just to let you know
some of the other people who were
selected ahead of you
Zac Efron Ryan Gosling Daniel Craig Ryan
Reynolds Stephen Hawking Steve booth
Steve Buscemi was taken ahead of you as
well okay you you agree with that you
understand that right 44 now all that's
leaning dance it's gone all those days
of you know trying to be a good looking
guy over for me no I'm trying to be more
like yes yes we got our Christmas party
today where we've been mailing it in all
morning long just like pre-recorded
these shows know and like and like in
what a vacation for three weeks and then
came back after the new year so you're
still in
yes we're live right now yeah yeah you
are
it's too hard sorry about the draft
though I hope I hope your holidays still
great you know you have a great holiday
and I hope Axl gets everything he wants
see how to dance
Axl go Vikings out of the playoffs
wait that's mean to say all right
yeah hey thanks happy holiday thanks but
I'll be everybody okay that's Josh
Duhamel feel bad for the dude 44 it's
over the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]